[موسيقى]
انا بقيت لعمر ال 18 نزلت على الجامعه
ببيروت كنت عم بعمل كيمياء وكان طموحي انه
كفه بهذا المجال بمجال الكيمياء لحد ما
قررت انه بدي افوت على الجيش
من انا وصغيره كنت بحب افوت على الجيش
وكنت تشوف كنت تشوف الجيش على الطريق من
انا وصغيره واقول انه انا شي نهار كمان
انا بدي البس البدله وبفوت على الجيش فبس
انفتح المجال للاناث انه يفوتوا على الجيش
اخذت هذه الخطوه قررت انه بدي اترك
الجامعه وافوت على الجيش
[موسيقى]
بالجيش فات بنات قبل فكانت الفكره شوي
صارت عم تنتشر بالمجتمع عم بيشوفوا العالم
الاناس بالجيش بالبدله فالعالم ما كثير
يعني كان في تردد او او شي هيك يعني
العالم كانوا متقبلين للفكره اكثر
مهام اللوات الجويه يعني كل ما يكون في شي
على الارض مهمات على الارض لويت الجويه عم
بتكون عم بتامن دعم جوي لهذه القوات
الموجوده على الارض لو شو ما كانت المهمه
محاربه المخدرات مراقبه حدود او شو ما كان
[موسيقى]
اكيد تشجع كل النساء يرفضوا هذه التجربه
اذا بس يرجع ينفتح المجال يصير في تطوير
نحن كان في ناس قبلنا وكانت تجربتهم ناجحه
وهذا اللي شجعنا انه انه نحن نكفف فاكيد
انا بشجع الكل انه بس يصير في مجال اكيد
يجربه